hello and welcome to this video playing
craft souq the german german term which
basically translates to a powerful move
so let's see how powerful is going to
play okay so this is fairly frequently
seen this line the g6 line um why does
better than this in this variation let's
see how black handles this the main
issue is that you have problems with
them with the c6 bond let's see I can
maybe even start with B three bits okay
this is not a bad idea
black is really not playing c5 or all
that quickly maybe maybe now as a pawn
SEC I don't think that can be enough but
maybe he can do it if I get the Bishop
to c5 this is going to be very him yeah
okay not putting it on c5 actually
doesn't do all that much but I mean just
stop the [ __ ] bone from moving let's
see what he what he does Queen a for
life I'm not sure that this helps all
that much yeah okay if I go Bishop to d2
isn't that okay Bishop d2 Queen to b6
now maybe
even just playing before then it's
probably quite okay I'm also wondering
if just twenty two is good because I
mean I'm winning a temple in some way he
has to take it almost like I don't think
maybe twin eight-six but I think taking
is most likely and then look to see one
I should stop the see porn
oopsie a drug see one I'm just stopping
it he should he should think about a5 a5
a4 if that is an idea if you would trade
a plants like a5 a4 take that's
definitely helpful I'm not sure if you
can get it in actually this is the thing
after a four I might just go before but
I also have a bishop before that that's
actually quite nice let's do this
wait rook c1 a4 Bishop before a b3 it's
still good for what it's very good
forward a4 became now an interesting
idea is to play pawn to a4 simply fix
this let's do it
now the simple threat is rook c5 that
wins the pawn basically don't really
know if he's got something good against
it
don't see a good move
maybe c5 just giving it up and then play
like c5 rook takes rook takes pawn takes
knight c6 and try to play this upon down
at least then the knight is good on c6
no you have to go see fine if it's the
best defense I wonder if they have
something else here
Bishop g5 but it doesn't too much snow
yeah I should take a think and this one
yeah that is a quite reasonable defense
of IDM it's not going to be that easy
for me now to to keep all this
I wonder okay look see one giving this
up this would be age not easy not easy
at all okay it don't work does it work
yeah I do
let's do this first if he goes Bishop f8
actually not so clear what I'm doing
then that's a good defense amethyst to
c5 move was really putting up a very
very substantial resistance so let's
keep it for the moment and then you
might just go Bishop g7 back
I have 94 which is some which is an idea
94 Knight takes e5 and then Bishop f4
it's an interesting move trying to take
play knight c6 yeah that's probably a
good idea
mmm
maybe not he's got stuff like whoops eh
rook c8 looks like a good reply at
anything okay that doesn't really do all
that much so c6 mc6 playing for c7 rook
see one there is 93 actually
and I still should do it we should have
eight
so if I go c7 now I could not be 5 next
year yeah
threatening night 87 now and then a 7
sue should win some material right
before maybe that was lame what I did
couldn't couldn't quite figure it out
that shit's good now
whoo what's still quite tough really
yeah honestly I think this is just
pretty bad for work and it's it's
basically not possible to get equal play
anymore
but let's let's see what was what was
best be three must be kind of okay
create five yeah this is this is
actually debatable you can try all kinds
of things so that makes sense
Queen d2 should be to a 4 a 4 with
Bishop e3 is also quite sensible so
Queen d2 just check what happened in
five wickets to see 108 so now probably
a 5 is not a 4 is not good because of
c-5 really the way we we we saw that
it's probably really better to do this
just stop this principal break and we'll
be forced into we get 4 per force into
this and that must be really noisy this
is like I'm stopping this forever and
black has a hard time to get these
pieces somehow sorted if he would
somehow I can I to c4 I don't but it
doesn't happen just doesn't happen and
this is a lot better here c5 is a good
move and probably black is fine after
that I really think so
yeah and the engine is on zero it's just
not a surprise when I had this on the
board I was reading mmm that that that
cannot be radium yeah but should we of
Cour keep it for the moment that's very
not much else King f8 a stronger yeah
black is basically okay because the
pawns don't do much you know I really
cannot do much with it and here yeah it
should be
94 was probably a good move I mean the
reasoning behind it was not right
because my original idea was to play
Bishop f4 but after the ATIS doesn't
make any sense so I went c6 which also
doesn't seem to be great
rook c8 Luke c1 and now 93 still leads
to a playable position for Black Knight
at least for the moment 93 rooks III
look good for me let's see it looks very
dangerous but it seems like okay and
currently I'm in the pin so I cannot
move my knight this is why this is
played King 7 might be 5 and here I'm
not promoting you should be 6 no it's
not easy for black but it's that of
course clearly preferable to this now
after c7 I'm probably winning very
likely did not play in the best possible
way yeah Knight a 7 I thought that this
would probably win but it wasn't super
sure I can just take c8 and that's
stupid I was thinking I need to move the
rook here and I don't know and also I
didn't see what after hook c1 how he
saves himself and an injured indeed he
doesn't Luke c6 was system play quick
move with no time so at least I didn't
completely spoil it anyway it's just
difficult when you have no time at all
ok guys thanks for watching